Hey Marilyn ein mr.  Gus und ich lieben es
, Musik und Filme zu produzieren, also
denke ich gerade darüber nach, Channings
Leidenschaft zum Beruf zu machen, und schließlich habe ich
drei Fragen an Sie, Frage Nummer
eins, wie es möglich ist, dass ein kleiner
unwichtiger Musiker wie ich reinkommt
oder bleibt  im musikbusiness weil
ich weiss das das musikbusiness
sehr riskant ist und ich einfach nicht will
dass mir was zu schief läuft wäre es
cool wenn ihr mir da ein paar tipps gebt äh
meine zweite frage ist eine kleine
ethikfrage ich  würde gerne wissen was denkst du
was ist der sinn des lebens und
welchen platz nehmen musik und kunst in
der welt ein frage Nummer drei und die
letzte ist wolltest du jemals
sänger oder musiker werden danke
für die beantwortung meiner fragen und  sorry für
mein unglaublich schlechtes englisch ich bin ein riesen fan
von dir und ich wünsche dir alles
gute für die zukunft und viel glück vielen dank auf
wiedersehen egal ob du
popsongs oder rocksongs schreibst oder filmmusiken schreiben willst
ich auch wieder
Übrigens und ich finde es so wichtig
, sich selbst zu vertrauen, seinem Geschmack zu vertrauen,
ihnen zu vertrauen, dass man weiß, was man tut,
und natürlich ist es toll, wenn man Leute
um sich hat, die einem Input geben, aber seiner
eigenen Stimme vertrauen und  vertraue ihnen, was
du versuchst, was du versuchst
, durch deine Musik zu verfolgen, die es so gibt,
dass du niemals versagen kannst, wenn du dir
ansehen kannst, was du produziert hast, und sagen kannst, dass ich
stolz darauf bin, und egal wie viele
Leute hier sind, hier ist das  Ich stehe
für diese Grenze, den Sinn des
Lebens, das ist eine zu große Frage für dieses
kleine Interview, denke ich, und aber ich
finde es sicherlich sehr sinnvoll,
jeden Tag Musik machen zu können, Musik zu schreiben
und das absurd genug zu wissen
Musik, die ich für mich selbst schreibe und
weil ich muss, weil ich will, ich
habe den Drang dazu, und dass diese Musik
für andere Menschen tatsächlich etwas bedeutet
, was meinem Leben viel Sinn gibt, als ich
aufwuchs, war mein Haus mit mir gefüllt,
ist wie meins  Eltern  sind klassische
Musiker und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass
Musik ein so großer Teil meiner
Persönlichkeit und meiner Ausdrucksweise ist,
dass es nie einen entscheidenden Moment gab,
in dem ich mich entschied, dies zu tun,
und ich denke, der Moment, als ich
anfing  Als ich 13
Jahre alt war, fühlte ich mich wie ein entscheidender Moment
, Songs zu schreiben, aber es war immer ein Teil dessen, wer ich
bin und was ich tue